We just took an initial look at
how we can use Aria rolls and
properties to specify the semantics for
a particular element.
However, we should remember that native
HTML elements have implicit semantics.
For example, input type= checkbox
implicitly has a role of checkbox.
This means two things.
Firstly, there is usually no need
to redefine default semantics and
input type equals checkbox does not
need an extra role equals checkbox
attribute to be announced as a checkbox.
We'll come to an exception
to this rule later on.
Secondly, sudden HTML elements have
restrictions on what ARIA role and
attribute values may be
used effectively on them.
Most of the time unless you're
doing something pretty weird,
you won't run into any issues.
But the ARIA in HTML spec has a table
explaining what ARIA may and may not be
used with each type of HTML element
in case you want to get creative.
For example a text field input type =
"text" may not have a role attribute
applied.
Speaking of implicit semantics,
we mentioned earlier that
HTML landmark elements
may be used to help assistive technology
users to find their way around the page.
ARIA also offers a set of landmark and
document structure roles.
Many of these are redundant
with HTML5 semantic elements.
But depending on what browser
versions you need to support,
it may be necessary in some cases to
use both an HTML5 semantic element and
a redundant ARIA role.
For example,,
breaking the general rule of not
redefining default semantics.
Because the default semantics may
not be fully supported in this case.